majority of what you're saying but I
think the point that seems to get uh
missed out these days is that
you're you have more feminine energy
that's because you're born that way we
have more masculine energy because we're
blown away I think the society now the
problem is to say we're trying to make
each other so similar even though we're
much similar than we're different we
need to appreciate the differences
between us so I don't think there's any
benefits to a man being feminine even
though this is what females are
requesting nowadays I want my guy to be
more in touch with the feminine so
there's actually no benefit to it